they say history comes alive in the
pages of books and that couldn't be
truer for a college in upstate New York
last year researchers at Union College
discovered what they believe is a lock
of George Washington's hair it was
tucked into a two hundred and
twenty-five year old Almanac inside an
envelope labeled Washington's hair
I think the first thought is oh oh em
gee I can't believe this is Washington's
hair we have Washington's hair and I
think there was a thought of how do we
know for sure we need to need to do more
research we can't say for sure with the
hair being over 200 years old
experts say DNA testing is likely to be
inconclusive luckily the historical
evidence leads scholars to believe the
hair is indeed from the first American
president the almanac belonged to the
son of general Philip Schuyler who
served under George Washington in the
Revolutionary War and later co-founded
Union College it wasn't unusual in those
days for people to give locks of hair to
their colleagues to their close friends
oh this historic hair that's been tucked
away for centuries will soon have a new
life to remind future generations about
one of this country's founding fathers I
want to be able to display it after that
process and people definitely have it on
display in college or everybody to come
see I mean we like to connect it up with
the stylers a little bit of our own
history